good morning
my name is alison ord i have a small
company called mineral dynamics
and i write and learn through the
university of western australia
i also cycle i'm a geologist
and i enjoy and worry about all aspects
of the deformation of rocks
i'm particularly interested in the
application of non-linear dynamics to
understanding how rocks deform
and in this presentation i explore
completely data-driven
approaches to the analysis of
mineralogical data
from drill holes the raw data must speak
for themselves
my goal is to discover the underlying
dynamics of the mineralizing system
and the cross correlations between
mineral concentrations
produced by the interconnected processes
that developed a particular mineral
system
i thoroughly enjoyed attending the
wolfram summer school in 2019
and being inspired by stephen i think it
would be truly great
if exploring the behavior of rule 30
would result in much
improved algorithms for exploring and
predicting drill core data
so why do we drill anyway the minerals
council of australia has this all worked
out
they noted number four of their 30
things that more than 40
mined metals and rare earths are used to
produce just one single smartphone
in the small print in the lower right
hand corner it says that one ton
of mobile phones yields more gold than
one
tonne of gold ore
everything comes from somewhere if we
didn't grow
it was mind our earth is a finite
resource
you might do better to work out how to
improve recycling
than to explore and mine our earth but
please keep listening
the welcome stranger nugget the largest
ever found
weighed in at about 110 kilograms when
discovered in 1869 in victoria australia
the nugget is in the foreground in the
sepia print on the top right
with those involved in its discovery it
shows more clearly as a golden fake on
the left hand side with a couple of
diggers
the golden eagle is the largest nugget
ever found in western australia
weighing in at about 32 kilograms in
1931
displayed in the lower two pictures by
the boy who fell over it
and his father these guys were just
plain lucky
so how do we explore today
well mostly still by luck and pragmatism
my three colleagues in the top photo
mark monroe in the middle and bruce
hobbs on the right
are looking out over the vast expanse of
the west australian bush
with a salt flat behind them worrying
about that billion dollar question
how do we predict the gold distribution
the middle picture is of sunrise dam
just nearby
it's the second largest gold deposit in
australia
the bottom of the pit is 760 meters deep
here
and there is mining a further one
kilometer underground
this used to be under a salt flat and at
the bottom is what we want to see in
drill core
gold study of these systems has now
entered the big data era
with more and more data collected at
finer and finer scales
in the present era where big data are
generated routinely by mineral
exploration companies
it is essential to have rigorous
procedures for extracting quantitative
information
from these large data sets for
developing rigorous ways of prediction
both interpolation and extrapolation and
of deriving knowledge
and understanding from such expensive
data
can rule 30 provides such procedures
a dominant characteristic of
mineralizing systems is the irregularity
in patterns of alteration and a
mineralization at all spatial scales
from thin
section to regional scales an important
question is
is this irregularly purely stochastic
that is the result of random processes
or are the underlying processes
deterministic
understood here to be the result of
well-defined chemical and physical
processes
is there information in this
irregularity that gives us a better
understanding of these deposits
the mineralizing systems are determined
to be multi-scale in nature with
episodic histories
strong interactions between processes
operating at the various spatial scales
produce ambiguous overprinting relations
and pathogenetic sequences
the sequential order in space and
interpreted to be in time
of mineral deposition in an or deposit
what happens if we try to use some
science to explore
as a first step let's consider a
mineralizing system to be a chemical
reactor
this golden egg is our reaction vessel
it hosts the processes resulting in
alteration and mineralization within the
earth's crust
we must have an open flow chemical
reactor
this lower bluish box represents
fractured rock
allowing for input of heat and fluid at
the base of the system
within the egg a self-enhancing system
of exothermic reactions
results in alteration endothermic
mineralization
is initiated by higher temperatures
heat and mass are lost out of the top of
the egg as a result of advection and
conduction
the size of your body is proportional to
the input of heat and fluid
no wind no fuel no flames
these chemical reactors incorporate
interactions between deformation heat
fluid flow and chemical reactions as
shown in this figure of dynamical
non-linear feedback processes
modeling of such a system results in
irregularity at all scales
the system appears to be random or there
is a hint of periodicity
determinism there's always some degree
of prediction
recurrence similar states are revisited
in both space and time
chaotic transitions one type of
irregular behavior switches to a
different type of irregular behavior
so where do we go for understanding we
consider a couple of templates for
non-linear dynamical behavior
the lawrence relationships which
describe convection
whether it is of the earth's mantle
fluid flow within the earth's crust
or of the earth's atmosphere and the
rustler
relationships used to describe chemical
reactions
convection in earth's mantle shown on
the right hand side
is equivalent to convection in the
kettle the outline of africa
is shown clearly in yellow to the left
of it is a sinuous red
surface near surface mass trailing north
and northwest this represents upwelling
of hot material at the north atlantic
rise
such rally banara convection is well
described by the lawrence equations
the attractor for which is shown here
using wolfram language
similarly for the rustler attractor as a
descriptor for chemical reactions
here is a wolfram demonstration
consider also the scott gray
relationships
we envisioned a regional array of
chemical reactors
each representing an ore body
such dynamical templates inspire cindy
the sparse identification and nonlinear
dynamics
described by brenton and colleagues for
extracting the governing equations from
data
so we have a model for a mineralizing
system which has us input various
controlling factors
it has our golden egg as its focus
and from which we can contain output
signals for say
the mineralization the host rock
alteration
the vein and blecher infill
we think that orogenic gold systems
should be analyzed as non-linear
dynamical systems
there is a suite of tools available to
do this
the array of tools is quite large but we
have concentrated on recurrence plots
since recurrence is a fundamental
property of dynamical systems
the use of such tools enables a range of
quantitative measures
and cross-correlations that are not
otherwise obvious
on the left we have seven core trays
containing cores of rock obtained from
drilling down into the earth
each bit of core is a meter long and
they are laid out top to toe
the color reflects the chemical
composition of white micas
derived from near infrared reflectance
spectra of the core
we now have many kilometers of such data
providing detailed mineralogy and
chemistry
at millimeter and even micron resolution
on the right the gold load is noted to
be associated with the blue or iron poor
white micas
consider now given the previous
discussion that the behavior of a
mineralizing system is described in the
large dimensional state space
with coordinates comprising the state
variables
fluid velocity fluid pressure
temperature
strain rate and the rates of the n
chemical reactions in the system
a drill hole spatial data series for say
gold concentration
is a projection from the large
dimensional state space
onto a one-dimensional spatial series
the drill hole
the drill hole mineralogical signals we
observe are the projections from a space
defined by these space variables onto a
single drill hole record that we observe
at a particular place
as a one-dimensional spatial series
the tekken's theorem states that the
complete dynamics of such systems may be
encapsulated in a data series
for a single state variable collected
through that system
the reason for this as expressed in the
mineralizing system above
is that in systems where all the state
variables are coupled
the behavior of one depends on the
behaviors of all the others
and so the data series for one variable
as behaviors of the
other variables encoded within it
consequences that the attractor
constructed from a spatial delay
embedding of information
from a single line of data collected
through a mineralizing system
should represent the entire mineralizing
system
working through this here is a plot of
log gold concentration down a drill hole
left top right bottom here also is a
plot of chlorite abundance similarly
down the drill hole
how do we measure their irregularity
recurrence plots visualize the
trajectories of system states and phase
space
and the probability that given states
recur within a given margin
the top pro summarizes the previous
discussion coupled sets of non-linear
processes lead to chaotic behavior in
space and time
the behavior of such systems can be
represented by an attractor that is a
plot of all possible states of the
system
the currents here is shown as dot two
dots close to each other
within a radius defined volume on in
this case the lawrence attractor
such recurrences blacken the plot on the
right describing the behavior of the
system
for given embedding dimension and lag
the bottom row starts with the color
distance map followed by the recurrence
map
plotting a recurrence within the
prescribed radius
the lengths of the diagonal lines are
the measure of predictability
the recurrence plot can be converted to
a recurrence network that mimics the
attractor for the system
here a crude version of the lawrence
attractor is obtained
so we start exploring recurrence plots
for drill core data
on the top left the plots say that the
distributions are not the result of
random processes
there's strong laminarity the vertical
and horizontal lines in both
this is evidence of many chaotic
transitions each plot supplies a
fingerprint or dna
for the ore body on the top right we
compare gold with serocyte
and note windows of similar behavior
beneath this on the left we note strong
correlations between gold occurrence
and chaotic transitions in serious site
and on the bottom right we ask what
these transitions might represent
with a mineralizing chemical reactor
to what extent might we be able to map
these transitions
and now to rule 30 as stephen wolfram
says the step up
setup for real 30 is extremely simple
once dealing with the sequence of lines
of black and white cells
given a particular line of black and
white cells the colours of the cells on
the line below
are determined by looking at each cell
and its immediate neighbors
and applying a simple rule i drill the
result for comparison with the drill
core described above
and explore the behavior of the central
column
it's a cellular automaton it has no
physics associated with it
certainly has no partial differential
equations associated with it
i can't build a damn wall with it as far
as i know
however there i was at the wolfram
summer school i was working on
recurrence quantification analysis in
wolfram language with
philips for application to geological
data
and i heard of rule 30. so why not go
through the same analysis for rule 30.
here are a few results on the left are
data from the drill core
and on the right from rule 30 11
864 points in each case
here are the 3d spatial attractors for
the two sets of data
what is particularly stunning is not
that they appear different
but that there is a clear attractor for
all 30 at all
there's no clear attractor for white
noise
increase the embedding dimension for
white noise and the attractor continues
to fill space
this attractor does look much like those
i have derived from folded rocks
with recurrence but not perfect
periodicity
these distance maps are derived from the
data using flip philips is wool from
language code from last year
that for the drill core shows both
diagonal lines representing determinism
the predictability of the system and
horizontal and vertical lines
representing phase transitions
the intermittency on the system rule 30
also displays such characteristics
indeed
at the first glance diagonal lines
dominate the pattern
more than for the drill core we're going
to zoom now into windows within these
figures
each window 200 points wide and
succeeding windows displaced by 150
points from bottom left to top right
up the leading diagonal look at the
richness of the detail
the variations in the behavior for rule
30 at least as much as for the drill
core
it's all very exotic and provides
wonderful visuals for t-shirts and
tablecloths and rugs
but we need quantitative measures for
this behavior
and weber and marvin and colleagues have
provided these over the years
the next slides will show results for
these measures
recurrence rate recurrent points falling
within a given radius for the number of
points in the signal
determinism recurrent points forming
diagonal line structures
predictability of the system laminarity
recurrent points forming vertical line
structures intermittency of the system
trapping time average length of vertical
line structures
the length of time or space the system
remains in a specific state
trend a measure of system stationarity
entropy the shannon information entropy
of probability distribution of the
diagonal line lengths
complexity of deterministic structures
and chaos one over the length of the
longest diagonal line
interpreted to be equivalent to the
maximum lapen of exponent of the system
lower the value the more predictable the
system
and here are those results
recurrence determinism
laminarity trapping time
trend entropy
chaos at first glance the only obvious
difference
is constant nature of chaos for all 30.
the magnitudes of all the measures are
crudely similar
here are the same results this time i
look for possible similarities or
opposites in the patterns
the green lines for the drill core pick
out minima in all measures at about the
same points
i find the task a bit harder for the
rule 30 data
and the purple lines are the result
in summary i found it difficult to
distinguish data created by rule 30 from
these data
for the abundance of some element
collected progressively down the drill
core
the main difference to date is that rule
30 data reflect just one lyapunov
exponent
rather than the variability represented
by drill core data
two different pieces of software were
used to explore this curiosity
using different embedding dimensions and
lags and other variables used in
recurrence quantification
analysis same results
conclusions analysis using recurrence
plots
shows that the apparently irregular data
sets of mineral
composition and abundance from the
sunrise dam orogenic
gold system are indeed the result of
deterministic processes
operating within a non-linear dynamical
system
although the dynamical attractor for
this system is difficult to define
non-linear prediction indicates that the
embedding dimension for the attractor
is in the range seven to ten so the
number
of coupled physical chemical processes
that operated to produce the system
is in this range also the entropy and
first liapanov exponent for this system
are relatively small meaning that the
information content of these data sets
is large and that prediction over useful
ranges
is possible it's uncanny the extent
to which the analysis for rule 30 might
be inferred
to show have similar interpretation
in the present big data environment
where huge data sets are routinely
collected in the minerals industry it is
important to extract as much knowledge
from such data as possible
so remind yourself of our central
questions
are they apparently are regular data
sets obtained
from drill core of whatever data
stochastic
the result of random processes or
deterministic
the result of well-defined physical and
chemical processes
is there information in these irregular
data sets
that gives us insight into the
mineralizing process
recurrence analysis is a method for
rapidly extracting knowledge
from these large expensive data sets and
for providing fingerprints to
characterize a quantitatively
and compare data sets do you have any
better ideas
thank you for listening please let me
know if you have any questions
here is our bibliography which may
answer some
of them